estos campos de amapolas dormidera serán
la base de la economía en afganistán de
estas plantas se extrae el opio
necesario para fabricar drogas como la
heroína y esta nación concentraba entre
el 80 y el 90 por ciento de la
producción mundial pero tras la retoma
del poder de los talibanes hace un año
su plantación ha quedado prohibida
alegando que quieren eliminar el vicio
ya que en la actualidad el 8% de los
afganos son drogodependientes cifras
alarmantes para las autoridades
bueno también
tras un decreto emitido por el líder
supremo del emirato islámico de
afganistán se informa a todos los
afganos que a partir de ahora el cultivo
de amapola está estrictamente prohibido
en todo el país
no
una decisión sorprendente ya que tras la
invasión de eeuu este grupo islamista se
financió gracias a la exportación de
opio un negocio que convirtió a
afganistán en un narcoestado en el que
el 15 por ciento de su pib dependía de
este producto pero que también dio
sustento a más de 500.000 familias el
20% de su población ahora muchas de
estas personas ven como lo que fue su
único sustento se convirtió en una
práctica sujeta a duros castigos y en
una tierra tan árida como ésta las
opciones son pocas
sembrar otros cultivos que no sean la
amapola adormidera no genera ganancias
es nuestra ganar aquí y si no se nos
permite cultivar amapola perder hemos
tenido ver la erradicación de la amapola
es una victoria en la guerra contra las
drogas a nivel global pero a su vez
supone otro golpe más para la economía
de los afganos especialmente cuando un
90% de ellos sufre inseguridad
alimentaria